welcome to episode 68 of the michaela
peterson podcast
this episode was co-hosted with my dad
jordan peterson
we interviewed russell brand the russell
brand
which was awesome this episode was very
intense we go deep
we spoke about family life seeing the
divine in others fame
and much more i can't even begin to
describe it really
russell has just released an audio book
revelation connecting with the sacred in
everyday life
which is linked below and available at
audible.com russell's podcast under the
skin
is also available on luminary which is a
subscription podcast service
but i got you a month free you can get
that by going to luminary.link
mp also linked below please remember to
hit subscribe if you enjoy this
episodes every sunday and wednesday this
episode is brought to you by ground news
you may have seen ground news on your
twitter feed recently they are the
company behind the blind spotter
a twitter tool that went viral earlier
this week the tool tells you if you have
a balanced news diet on twitter or if it
skews one way
you can use the tool on yourself or on
any account on twitter mine's skewed
slightly right
based on the news sources i interact
with it's a great complement to the
ground news app
a news comparison platform that helps
you see the full story and adopt a more
balanced news diet
with the app you can easily compare how
sources from across the political
spectrum are covering a story
and easily see how outlets are
manipulating a story to fit an
underlying narrative the blind spot
feature tackles coverage bias and
reveals if a news story is getting
balance coverage
or only being ignored by outlets on the
left or on the right
unlike every other news source these
days ground news isn't a political news
app
only interested in giving you the full
story regardless of your political
ideology
easily lift the veil on media bias and
download the free ground news app just
click on the link
in the description below or go to ground
dot news
this episode is also brought to you by
self-authoring can't not mention
them self-authoring was developed by my
dad over the last 30 years with help
from two other phds at mcgill and
harvard
it has past authoring allowing you to
write out your past
great for trying to work through trauma
although please wait
at minimum a year after the trauma is
gone
so you don't re-traumatize yourself it
has present authoring which helps you
write out your present and identify
flaws that you can work on figuring out
and future authoring which helps you
make a plan for the future with code
mp you get 10 off at selfauthoring.com
i really believe in this program if you
don't have a goal you have nothing to
aim for
this helps fix that it's also 30 or less
with my code so it's very affordable for
what it is
selfauthoring.com codemp enjoy this
episode
it was certainly enjoyable for me and
again remember to hit subscribe to stay
[Music]
updated
[Music]
russell brand welcome to the podcast
makayla thank you very much for having
me
i know it's really late where you are so
thanks for doing this and making it
possible
i'm a little bit starstruck gotta say
it's not actually
that late it's just an indication of how
my lifestyle has changed what it
actually is in objective terms
is 8 45 but in my new life
at 8 45 is late because
i live with a four-year-old and a
two-year-old and of course their mother
my children i uh urgently point out
and like so now everything is
everything is different there's so much
um
life around me michaela but of course
also so much death i'm handling the
death part they're handling the life
part
okay can you delve into that a little
bit what do you mean so much death we're
bloody exhausting these children
like the children the animals there's
dogs there's cats everywhere i look
there's
more life that that's probably a dog
hair in my mouth right now
it's just uh it invades every every
facet of my being
see that's why you're supposed to have
children when you're young and stupid
instead of old and wise
yeah i see that now thank you very much
i wish i
met you when i was 20. i possibly
wouldn't have been able
to absorb the information then either no
no that's another problem i think you
have to have children when you're young
by
accident that's how i did it it worked
out really well
yeah is that what if you do you mean you
have children or that you are
you i do i i have a three and a half
year old girl
well that's good yeah i can see that'll
be good i can see that will be good
yeah that's fine yeah there's no other
way i could have done it
yeah you don't think you could have
handled it well how have things you said
you have a
four-year-old and a two-year-old that's
precisely right yeah
and they've been home all the time
because of coved too huh well as a
matter of fact we like they do have like
a
play group that they can attend
part-time
and actually in again i should
probably from um most people's
perspective it's a it's
kind of a breeze i mean i'm you know i'm
not
i'm not a coal face i'm not running a
farm
and it's actually in loads of ways
absolutely blissful in fact all this
information really
is just to sort of provide some context
for how 8 45 in the evening
when more sophisticated people are
sitting down to dine
is to make some kind of witching hour
yeah yeah that's fair enough i'm i'm
getting tired around seven o'clock
uh especially if scarlett comes in at
night
um i wanted to ask that just before i
forget and this is a question for both
of you guys but we could start off with
russell um what what's been the most
difficult
part of having kids for you other than
being a sleeper
early
well i don't know
if anything about it has been
jarringly difficult because
it's been such a total transformation
from not only a life you know i had a
life i'm a performer and like sort of
celebrity has been a component in my
life and
so so both being a performer and being a
celebrity can both
i i suppose amplify
aspects of self-centeredness a way that
can
in retrospect be rather ruthless and
having children
in a way that i that i'm present for has
been very very grounding
so it's very difficult to to break it
down
because it's so such a holistic change
it's very difficult to break it down
into components and because it is
overall
so glorious and sort of wonderful and
profound it's difficult to
frame it as being in in any way negative
but it has been wholly wholly
transformative in a way that's
[Music]
beneficial beneficial incredibly
important part of maturation
and like had i had this happen to be in
my 20s
i don't think i would have been able to
have
rooted myself yeah that's fair
i was pretty wild before i had skype
really
oh yeah like in an uncomfortable way and
i mean getting pregnant you have
absolutely like you don't
really have much of a choice if you're
pregnant and you're going to have a kid
then
you're immediately a healthy sober
person
so unless you want real trouble yeah
unless you want real trouble but um that
switched things around
really quickly and then the first year
staying you have to be
pretty much attached like as a man if
you're a
good and you're there then it's one
thing but as a woman if you're
breastfeeding then you're just
completely attached to the baby for like
a year so that kind of takes away the
party element too and it was probably
it probably sped up
um it probably actually ended up
speeding up my career because it put the
partying on hold
which is a funny thing to say about
having kids
you know well my my observation for
young people
in university was that for example the
students i had
who who were studying psychology who
also started working in a lab and then
so we're working 12 or to 20 hours extra
a week
got better grades not worse doing more
things
well because they had to discipline
themselves and they quit wasting time
yeah and there's some real utility in
um shouldering the sort of
responsibility that stops you from
wasting time
and you asked about negative elements of
having children yeah i feel
i think in some ways similar to russell
at least with regards to what he said so
far is
there was virtually nothing about it
that was negative as far as i was
concerned
um i suppose i i
was somewhat um
it was difficult to sort out how the
attention was going to be split in the
household i missed your mother
when she was so occupied with the
infants
but having children more than made up
for that and
you know kids get a bad rap and people
think of them as
an impediment to freedom and it's such a
foolish way of thinking because
it's so remarkable to have children and
you can have the best relationship
you have the opportunity of having the
best relationship with anyone you've
ever had in your life when you have
children
and then all also someone is finally
more
important than you you know i mean
hopefully when you get married or you
fall in love with someone they're
as important as you or perhaps even more
so
but when you have children it's
definitively the case that
now someone is more important than you
and that's
that's such a relief and it is a it is a
crucial part of maturation to have that
happen
and and i don't believe that people i'll
get pilloried for this or maybe you will
because it's
your podcast i can take the blame i can
handle it i don't think
it's possible to grow up without having
children oh
it's unlikely he's still got it
what's that he said he's still got it he
can still drop a bond mop
that's gonna stir people up yeah well i
it's hard to grow up until someone's
more important than you
so why would you why would you why
wouldn't you continue being siberic and
and and living at least to some degree
for pleasure
so it's true but children are amazing
and so everyone out there who's thinking
about having children you should do it
because they're
they add they add to your life and then
when you're older like me i'm 60
almost 60 now i have grandchildren now
and
i can't imagine what my life how empty
my life might be
without that and more of that on the way
so yeah i know some rather brilliant
people as i'm sure
you both do that have a foregone or
decided against or unable to have
children
i suppose the values that are brought to
the surface in parenthood
perhaps duty devotion
and perhaps if there is a sort of some
transcendent component to your life and
i don't mean that in necessarily in a
spiritual
way but it's difficult to avoid the
connotations of that word
then perhaps perhaps maturation
is possible if you take for example like
a straightforward uh
mendicants life monasticism
celibacy devotion in a very uh
explicit way to god then would you
say that they are unable to to reach
maturity or what if it was a secular
version like devotion to the arts or to
a sort of a political cause do you not
think that that could
well of course that reminds me of
something i wanted to talk to you about
i read your book mentors which is this
book right here and
um one of the things that it made me
think about was
i've thought for a long while that
the one of the processes that marks the
transition from
childhood to adulthood is apprenticeship
and so one of the things nietzsche said
about the catholic church was that
the european mind this is speaking in
nietzsche's voice the european mind
disciplined itself
by adhering to a single interpretive
strategy for centuries
to explain everything under the
conditions on
to explain everything using the axioms
of a single intellectual system and that
disciplined
the european mind and enabled it then to
go off and use other disciplinary
strategies to discover other
to discover other ways of dealing with
the world maybe to develop science
for example and nietzsche was very
convinced that
you had to enslave yourself in one
manner or another before you could be
free
and that's an apprenticeship motif and
to me that's what you explored
in your book mentors you know you you
present yourself i believe as someone
who was striving in various ways to
mature and that you identified people
who came into your life as targets for
emulation that could impose a discipline
on you and help you mature you would
hunger for that like
like people do and yes i do think that
if you don't have children there are
other disciplinary strategies
that you can use to further your
maturation but it isn't obvious to me
that any of them are as
profound as having children and i mean
i've had a good career and
i've been very interested in
intellectual pursuits as well and
i suppose have disciplined myself in
some manner because of that but
i still stand by my um statement about
children
they're in a different category of of
profundity
it's partly because you have to take on
so much responsibility when you have
children
is it the sacrifice too i mean if you
think about people who
who work in churches or what what
russell was saying about
you know people who devote themselves to
god and it's kind of what they do is
kind of sacrificial and i suppose part
of what you do when you have kids is
sacrifice that
hedonistic part if you're going to be a
good parent
so is is part of what helps you mature
the sacrifice associated with having
children or is it something else
i don't know if that's part of what
helps you mature or if that's a
definition of maturation
is that it's a sacrificial act but you
know people
often think of sacrifice in terms of
loss but the reason you sacrifice
fundamentally is
to gain something higher that's that's
the sacrificial motif you give up
something that's
that's attractive in the present but but
the purpose of the sacrifices
is to is to to organize things
more effectively at a higher level of
being
so and that is a that is maturation that
that's the forestalling of immediate
pleasure for
medium to long-term um well-being and
maybe for more than you as well
okay um
i have a question even though i know
it's not my podcast
and when you transduce a metaphysical
idea like sacrifice
and sacrifices as an evocation of a
greater power
further down the line and you transduce
it into
materialist and rational rationalist
terms perhaps to make it more relevant
to a cultural group that don't
think in that way anymore do you think
that
we risk missing part and the essential
part of the mystery
that much of the devotional life by its
nature
doesn't have a a direct
uh translation in secularism
i.e of course yes you know i've heard
you say before
jordan that it's as if there were a
father that's a stern father that's
going to guide you and discipline you
and chide you into being a
stronger man or woman but like uh um but
i feel too that there is something that
what
that through sacrifice we are also
acknowledging that on this plane of
being
on this plane of being all our needs
cannot be met in fact
really all we can do is generate need
and by sort of sacrificing
food or sacrificing like sacrificing
something important
we reaffirm our connection to the
sublime
okay well i think that whenever you
bring a transcendent concept in some
sense down to earth
you risk inappropriately constraining it
if you assume that your act of bringing
it down to earth has
explained it fully so
i don't believe that my explanation of
sacrifice explains it fully
and so i think you can retain that
you can retain the enough you can retain
the advantages of ineffability
for example if if i assess a
piece of literature or film for
and make its metaphysical presumptions
more explicit i don't believe that that
necessarily takes away
from the film it it can because it can
be reductionistic but
it can add an additional by furthering
understanding
it can add an additional layer of of
utility to the
to the experience i've tried to do that
with the biblical lectures i've done
for example i i'm not trying to explain
everything away
although i do think that generally
speaking you should use the simplest
explanation that's at hand
so it's a risk but but
hopefully it can be a a risk that is
fundamentally productive
yeah i reckon that i suppose i suppose
that mentorship
and education is dependent on crossing
this space
between the ineffable and the at least
palpable or
the apprehendable justice destiny is
that if the ineffable stays entirely
ineffable then you can't put it to use
and i think you're absolutely right that
the mentorship does that because
and there's a profound religious
instinct there and i think it was really
operating in you
you you make reference to it a number of
times for example you had
by your own admission a strong tendency
to
um romanticize the women in your
in your life you say you deify them in
some sense or maybe more accurately you
perceive them that way to begin with and
then
over time in some sense the stars fall
away from your eyes but that's the
action of an instinct that would be the
anima projection from a union
perspective is that
there's a an instinct in you that's
pushing you towards development and the
way it manifests itself is by
illuminating
certain elements of your experience and
those might be
that might occur for example when you
meet a male figure
who you admire who you then start to
imitate
it's it's the deep workings of your
unconscious
illuminate that figure and make him say
stand out against the background because
you've apprehended that there's
something about his pattern of being
that addresses a lack in yours and the
same thing can happen in romantic
relationships and and that can al also
not be
purely illusory you know in some sense
when you
when you have a romantic relationship
with someone
you are chasing the divine in each other
now both of you may fall short
and the relationship may fall apart but
by seeing the divine in the person that
you fall in love with you also invite
them to manifest that
and by opening the door to that they're
actually more likely to manifest it
it's very complex it's very complex and
sophisticated instinct
i understand this i understand this i
have experienced this i recognize that i
have
spent a lot of time projecting through
my inability to comprehend my own
psychic energies i've projected onto
another
resources that were available perhaps
through tutelage
within myself one of the mentors i write
about in that book who's like
has been incredibly valuable in my life
when we first met like
by you know synchronicity or chance gave
me a copy of
the robert johnson's book on gold and
inner gold
which is a sort of an essay on
mentorship and have it you know holding
one another's goal
um and i think yes that
how mentorship has functioned in my life
has
i've gained a great deal of perspective
i've understood that they are kind of uh
psychic uh cynic decays
holding for me a space holding meaning i
recognize the fallibility of these
people
that i uh like adore or aspire to
but in my psyche they function as
coordinates i was just talking to a
brilliant therapist today
in therapy and like a and he said that
you know
that you don't need to overcome your
father and mother
in the physical world with them you need
to overcome the imprint of them
in your psyche and i said yes in a sense
they are hollowed out carapaces in
reality i don't mean that of any
disrespect to my actual mother and
father
but like the the mother and father that
i deal with and live in my psychic
landscape they don't live
in essex england you know um
so like i recognize yes that we can use
relationship as an external coordinate
to activate
dormant psychic energies
so there's a kind of reductionism in
that too
in some sense right because by by by
doing that
you reduce the the the
experience of the divine in someone else
to activation of an unconscious
um complex let's say but
one of the things you point out in the
book and and it's possible to go deeper
than this too one of the things you
point out in the book is that
when you allow or ask or invite someone
to be your mentor
you also allow them to manifest that
element of them that's most
mentor-like and they can do that
independently to some degree of their
other flaws
just like when you're a parent a father
you can act paternally
as a figure of authority even though you
are
by no means a perfect figure of
authority the child
still needs you to be the best authority
figure that you can be despite your
flaws and
and you will manifest that but
it it that's also not false
because the ideal that we're all chasing
we we don't know what its ultimate
reality is
you know if you have an instinct towards
further development let's say
what that means is that there's
something about you that
could be greater than it currently is
and we don't know the limits to what
that currently greater
could be and that's where the
the idea of mentorship let's say shades
into something like religious worship
because i suppose
if you think about the christian world
the ultimate mentor is christ
and you could say that being a christian
or you could say that being a
psychologist and
if you said it being a psychologist you
would say well it's by definition that
the ultimate mentor is christ
and what christianity has been as it
unfolds itself over the last
2000 years is an attempt to engage all
of the people within that belief system
in a dialogue about what that ideal
actually constitutes
you know and there's tradition that
feeds into that the biblical stories and
the corpus of tradition that goes along
with that but all of it is a
collective attempt to specify that ideal
so that people can use it as a target to
further
their development and that's not
delusional that
that furthering of development is
unbelievably useful practically
yes yes and forgive me because i have a
response question
once again and i want to ensure that
michaela who surely has had a lifetime
of tolerating this kind of business
her father exciting jung passes by
um like i would like to i would like to
say when
edinger in his analysis of willian
william blake's engravings from the book
of
job says um like of the passage where
yahweh
shows the behemoth and the leviathan to
job and says look upon the leviathan the
behemoth that i have made as i may be
edinger in his analysis says that yahweh
is saying to job here
that the all potentiality
is held in yahweh it is beyond good and
evil
how does this transition between an old
testament
version of god that requires of us to
become good
that god itself or himself or herself is
also good
how does this idea this interpretation
of our relationship with god this old
testament which
uh places this sort of obligation that
sort of
punishes job for his uh phatic
impersonation of worship how does that
evolve into the christian idea of christ
as the perfect mentor christ is perfect
why don't you ask a difficult question
[Laughter]
jesus well you know jung talks about
this a fair bit in answer to job
and that's a very difficult book to
summarize and it's also a very
terrifying book but
the upshot of it is essentially
something like this which is that
whatever god is the the best
element of him can plausibly
be brought forth as a consequence of the
manifestation of what's best in us
and that might be the willingness to
sacrifice and the willingness to trust
and the
and the the the courage to love your
neighbor the courage to love your enemy
and and this is a profound question it's
like
would reality shine a more benevolent
face upon us if we're all as good as we
could be
and that's the christian idea and
i i can't see that that idea is wrong
now
and and i think well certainly jung
interpreted the story of job in that
light and
he believed that job sort of set god
back on his heels so to speak
by by being a more moral agent
in some sense than god himself was but
underneath all that was this notion that
if you acted as if god was love if you
believed that and that would be manifest
in your perceptions and your actions
that
that would invite
the deity of love into existence
and that's true you know that you know
that when you
when you when you interact with people
with love
and there's a tremendous courage in that
it makes the world a better place and we
don't know how deep that reaches
you know it certainly reaches as deep as
humanity itself
but and is there something
transcendentally real about it be
beyond that uh who knows who knows
it's that's that's a far enough target
for
for anyone as far as i'm concerned
that's a hell of a question russell yeah
i'm just sitting here just like yep i'll
just
that was but but anyway
that's that's fine not so much because
you said
you know before we did this podcast we
were talking about mentors and you said
that
your your one of the things that you've
done is to pick someone to imitate
and to pull yourself towards them by
that process of imitation and then when
you got close you'd
pick someone else to imitate or to
compare yourself with compare myself
with not sure but it's the same thing
the comparison is the same thing because
when you compare yourself to someone
you start pulling yourself towards them
unless you get envious and resentful
yeah before we were before we hopped on
the podcast i was just talking about how
i have like i i consistently have i'm
getting a lot of opportunities with the
podcast i have but i consistently have
my dad to compare myself to
which i think is fine because i have
something to aim towards
and it's kind of something to get to and
that's what i've done throughout my life
is hey
i you know that person is really smart
and interesting
try and achieve what they're achieving
and then once you get there you pick
somebody above you and the problem is
that means you're always kind of
unfulfilled but it also means you're
always growing so that's what we were
talking about well that's also why
jung pointed out for example he believed
that the book of revelations had been
tacked onto
the new testament because the christ in
the gospels was
portrayed too much as a figure of mercy
whereas in revelations
christ is portrayed primarily as a judge
and jung's explanation for that was that
every ideal is a judge and the ultimate
ideal is the
ultimate judge and you could say the
ultimate ideal
judges your soul and because that's
virtually the definition of the ultimate
ideal and so the ultimate ideal is
something transcendent and divine
that judges your soul now what that
means
about the way the universe is
constituted again i have no idea but
but but the higher the ideal the more
severe the judge that's clearly the case
and that should make you quake i think
it does
when you're conscious when your
conscience assaults you in the middle of
the night for things that you've done
wrong it's because you're quaking
in your boots morally because you failed
to live up to this ideal
there's no escape from that not not not
truly
i don't believe there is
how are you two managing
to conduct the intimacy of a
father and daughter relationship in this
new medium i you know having two
children
my two little daughters myself i love
them so dearly they're children they're
not adults
of course but i um i felt like it made
me like fantasize a little
um you know i wonder if i'll work with
them i wonder who they'll be i wonder
who they'll be
the idea of um bringing your
relationship into this space
has it been challenging for for
for you michaela particularly when you
hold your father up
in such high regard and such high esteem
and i know you've been through a very
challenging time as a family person
thank god that you're both well now and
but
how is it to find yourself in this
situation that has a sort of a public
dimension to it um
yeah it it hasn't been easy i mean for
my entire
life especially when i've gotten older
i've said yes to
every opportunity that kind of came my
way just to see where it would take me
and i think that's something i learned
from my dad just just say yes to
everything and see what happens
um i started like formally working for
him in 2018
um because i'd already built his kind of
social media platforms
just the profiles on you know facebook i
knew how instagram worked and i was like
instagram's the new facebook like switch
we got to get you a profile there so um
and then i started like simple with
i was cutting youtube videos and just
making clips
and then i was booking theaters and then
i started
coordinating between companies or agents
um
and it's been complicated uh with family
it hasn't been it's not all fun and
games and we get into
serious work discussions where we're
we're talking about
i don't know maybe producing something
and whether or not that's a good idea
and it's
i i don't really have a comparison so i
don't know if it's more stressful than
working somewhere else like the other
places i've worked
when i was a kid i was working at like a
hockey rink and as a waitress
and i i was working at a club at one
point and it's not like that wasn't
stressful
so i'm still working in this position so
apparently i like it
uh and it's definitely challenging
you've taken a fair bit of public flack
i would say for people who because of
what's happened to me over the last
couple of years
because of people who doubt your
motivations and yes you know and who
feel that you might be exploiting me
which
i would like to state very forthrightly
is not the case
um quite the contrary you've been of
tremendous help but it's difficult to
keep those
boundaries straight i mean the problem
with working with family members is you
run into dual relationship
problems and you know many ethicists
think those are best avoided completely
and
there's some real wisdom in that but
that doesn't mean it's unethical to
enter into
a business relationship with a family
member but it does mean that it's
fraught with
difficulties it's difficult to be a
father
and also supervise michaela's role in
my business affairs for example because
it isn't clear when i'm one and when i'm
the other
and it's i suppose not clear to her when
she's
daughter and when she's employed there
are definitely benefits though
um i found like part of the reason i
thought that i was good
at the role i'm doing was because i was
more comfortable
pushing dads on on decisions that i
really believed he should do
um pushing much harder than
somebody else would push like me for
example like you would push
she's less she's less agreeable than me
so like quite a bit left
yeah so i could do i could make
congratulations
thank you it makes getting along with
people hard but uh it's
it's entertaining uh
yeah it was tricky i i mean i think i
like it
i've been i wonder forgive me
interrupting michaela i wonder when
the conversation has a propensity to
move into areas such as
archetypes and when such strong opinions
are being expressed
whether or not you feel like it could be
exposing just because of the
jordan your clinical background and the
type of conversations that you evoke
and i'm just talking about the actual
conversations himself let alone the sort
of secondary
component when other people start to
evaluate stroke
judge this stuff exposing in what way
what are you what are you thinking about
you mean violation of privacy
i i reckon provocative more like if
someone like i feel like if i was
talking to
my mother or father it's difficult to
imagine why my little
innocent albeit potent children like but
but with the parent like i feel like
that if my
mother or father was talking about sort
of archetypes and psychic energies and
parenting like you know i feel like that
i could potentially feel like hey
you know that sort of that territory is
not entirely academic and not atta
and not solely rhetorical but is uh
in this context is empirical and and i
think the very fact that you're doing it
evidence is is evidence of a great deal
of a
trust and uh rapport a sympatho between
you
but i just wondered if it like how how
it feels now that you're actually doing
it
i think i can i can answer that okay
i've got an answer too so
at least from my perspective people are
people have asked me is your dad like he
is on youtube at home and the answer is
yes
like you know generally speaking you
don't get a 90 minute shirt
like sermon like speech with nobody
interrupting
but we've been talking about
the meaning behind the biblical series
and myths
uh and talking about you know what do
you want to do
in your future sit since i can remember
so
it's not something new at all and it
doesn't seem uncomfortable because
that's how i was raised
and it doesn't having a public component
doesn't make it jarring
it because there's still
a distance right like even even in 2016
or 27 to
17 it was there's a distance between
reading about a newspaper it's weird
like you know you walk down the street
and dad was on a newspaper and i'd be
like
that's that's jarring but at home
it's not jarring even doing podcasts
like this it's intimate right it's just
us three so there's the public element
but
it would be maybe it would be different
if it was in front of a crowd
um but it hasn't really seemed less
intimidating you've had a different
experience
i think we're both relieved and pleased
to be doing something
together yeah that isn't intensely
focused on
like fatal or or highly painful
illness yeah that because that's just
it's just been
non that's just been non-stop for for
way too long way way too long and so
this is a
break from that it is very strange but
we're in a strange world
i'll never get accustomed i don't think
to the degree to which i've become
public
and that's something i wanted to ask you
about i mean you got famous
and there's nothing more appalling than
people who are
notorious or well-known whining about
their fame
and i don't want to do that um but
but it but it's still something
interesting to
note and to contemplate it try partly to
get a handle on
it's very it's been very difficult for
me to
reconceptualize my circumstances given
that i
became well known when i was relatively
older you know what happened after i was
55 and
it's strange strange to understand that
the conversation that we're having
you know is going to be watched and
listened to by
some hundreds of thousands of people or
perhaps more than that over time
um it's uncanny in some sense and
and surreal i just don't understand
those numbers so it doesn't
like i i can't i can't understand
those numbers yeah well you've go you've
grown up with
the the reality of youtube for example
like you've grown up in a world where
you could be a tv producer as well as a
tv consumer i mean when i was
grew up when i was your age even a bit
younger than that
when i was in my teen years we had two
tv channels
it wasn't long before that that you know
the united states only had
three and certainly there was never any
conceptualization that
any particular individual could become a
tv station or a media
center and so it's a very foreign
reality for me
and i guess i do have some sense of the
numbers perhaps because i've done so
many live talks and i've seen
very large crowds and in any case
the reason that michaela and i do this
in large part is because
well we're curious we wanted to see how
it would go but
i we also we're also seeing if we enjoy
it and
i'm happy to be here doing something
like this with her it's a real privilege
that goes back to you know having
children
i always i don't even have a joke i
don't even have a joke right now
i suppose too this has been enhanced by
my ill health in recent years but
i always feel that it's a privilege
to spend time with my children
and i have some sense of how fast time
goes
you know i've always had a very acute
sense of
the finitude of existence and so
and this is a good hint for people who
have
children but with regards to your family
members at all is
don't take it for granted no
every second you get
that isn't painful you should cherish
god a maudlin oh you came up with a joke
that's good i felt like uh i took it as
an expression of your love for one
another
just as a with the content that i've
watched and i imagine that would be the
motivation given the the
trials that you've endured with regard
to your health and
and then this is of course entirely
speculative
that you know that what preceded it in
the rather unique
certainly unparalleled cultural position
that
you jordan had occupied leading up to
the period of abstinence and it's a
accompanying medical
um complexity and i know that you know
but that's just tammy and i know
um michaela i know that sort of health
issues have been quite prevalent and
familiar with you and i'm familiar with
your work and i
sense that it would be it was a sort of
a culminative
expression of love and
gratitude and warmth and an opportunity
for you
both to be together and it's very
heartening to hear that it's that with
regard to your inquiry about the
nature of public life for me i
as i the older i get the more i
recognize it was an
unsophisticated attempt as perhaps or
early
grasps at the grail must be of trying to
heal the seminal wound of seeking some
kind of value
of trying to impose some kind of myth in
a mythilis world
some pursuit something of value to chase
after
and and then increasingly discovering on
as various uh points in the journey were
arrived at that it
couldn't fulfill me now i was sort of
comparatively old also like um you know
it wasn't like 16 i was like 30 when i
sort of became
well known when i started to make films
in america and things like that
and i always felt that there were i'm
sure numerous but at least two sort of
streams running one this sort of
like a need for validation and approval
on a scale that could only indeed be
provided by youtube numbers michaela
i'd need to see that speedometer
clocking up the hundred thousand two
hundred thousand there can never be
enough never a high enough number this
is the
the that lies at the root perhaps of all
addiction this
constant requirement for more than no
way of healing that wound not materially
at least
but some of that's actually some of
that's even actually healthy
russell i mean one of the things that we
do constantly is to evaluate our worth
by the responses of others and
you know if that's all you do that's a
mistake and
if you're doing it in a false way that's
also a mistake because then you're
gaining
as a consequence of doing something that
isn't real but
like the person who cares nothing for
what anyone else thinks is actually a
psychopath
not a saint and so it's easy for that
mechanism to go astray in a world that's
so dominated by social
media because you know when when
when before social media if you were a
teenager
it was really important how your peers
responded to you and and it should have
been because
that's part of apprenticeship you're
socializing yourself against the group
at that point and
their opinions should matter you use
them as a proxy for your parents to
escape from your parents
it's crucial even though it can go too
far but now that's
elevated to such an immense degree it's
like how it's like
it's like pornography or cocaine it's
you know it it pornography
harnesses the sexual drive and drugs
like cocaine
um hijack the the incentive reward the
pleasure circuit
and that they're unbelievably powerful
um
they're unbelievably powerful and it's
not surprising that you'd
be addicted to watching the numbers rack
up
i mean i i can see that and ex and
experience it as well
it's it's almost impossible to avoid
wanting to see the numbers climb and
to some degree that's egotistical and it
can really lead you astray but to some
degree it's just the natural
workings of a mechanism that is actually
there in part to keep you
socially acceptable insane
this uh potency that you describe with
uh cocaine and pornography it's
difficult to locate
uh comparably potent
influences when it comes to more
positive attributes
along alongside my like craving for
you know attention etc and and perhaps
some
warped ordinary anthropological drives
for
acceptance was always a vocational
urgency
a devotion like a an untapped or at
least
misguided devotion to that was always
present
there and i feel that sort of many of
the things that
i've heard you previously discussed
chime with this
if they do not express this exactly
that the problem of not having a shared
public myth is that everything is up for
grabs for acquire
being anointed with that status without
a
clear depiction of god god as ideals god
as
shared standards then why not just
pursue fame why not just pursue coca if
nothing means anything anyway
and i it's only sort of more recently
with with
you know in my case a sort of a
spiritual program through the 12 steps
through mentorship through the
obligations
uh that having people that are
relying me for their own recovery as
well as being a father
that these um i wouldn't call them
secondary i'm sure they're primary
characteristics but they were secondary
of my own behavior have been brought to
the forefront
have been realized actuated and like
that to your point earlier about sort of
mentorship is not that they just exhibit
the divine
and that it's you know it's only
relevant in so much it may activate the
the divinity or sublime energy in the
mentee
i see it's beyond that i see it somehow
as
a kind of symbiosis a kind of osmosis
a kind of that that isn't ultimately the
optimistic view of life
one of oneness one of love that's
separate that we are not
ultimately separate then therefore there
is
recourse to the universal there is a
possibility of me in admiring another
person or
adoring another person imbibing and
taking on these
attributes if the ultimate reality is
separation separateness
um you know i sometimes i think that
takes us back to the discussion about
the so-called christian transformation
of the idea of god
i've had jewish friends of mine point
out that the god of the old testament
gets a bad rap from christians to some
degree and that there's a lot more love
there than
than you might presume if you viewed the
new testament as a transformation of the
old testament god into the god of love
but we'll leave that aside i think it's
a valid point but
we'll leave that aside um
the ques if you're if if you're mentored
in a particular direction
well here's well here's how you might
conceive of it is there something that
all mentors
share in common well you would say so
because
they're all in the category mentors and
then you might say that well whatever
all mentors share in common
is the pattern of the divine again
that's almost by definition
now then there's a deeper question which
is okay if that
if what all mentors share in common is
the pattern of the divine
is that a real pattern and
the answer to that to some degree is
well you'll find that out by acting it
out
and it seems to me that the answer to
that has to be yes
i mean if we're adapted to the world
and if we pursue the fullest extent of
the possibilities of our adaptation
through mentorship
then and if that improves
the quality of our life then it seems
that
whatever it is that mentorship is
pushing towards
is is real insofar as it works in the
world
now does that mean it's materially real
or objectively real
i don't think that reality is bound
completely by the
categories of objective and subjective i
don't think that
captures the entire essence of reality
and
so but i don't believe that our instinct
towards mentorship
is a delusion i don't believe that our
religious instinct is a delusion either
even though all instincts can go astray
yes and when you were saying that this
uh this idea of christianity
uh being that you know if we live in
god's light or we aspire to god's light
or if we embody god's love then
that this is beneficial i was thinking
how as a
paradigm it's comparable to the taoist
idea that you are bringing the path into
being as you walk it that you are
created like that reality is interacting
with your consciousness that your
belief your perception the manner in
which you
behold and enact your life
influences life becomes life is life
and in in in that um you know tradition
and
let me tell you i know barely anything
about it it's sort of presented in a
more gnostic way
it's sort of somewhat more opaque it's
more minimal as one would expect to
housed as it is within that
culture but this the central message
appears to be the same
that there is no object here like that
these categories of
objective and subjective perhaps have to
be simultaneously held perhaps opposed
perhaps are interchangeable
that reality has been reality is being
believed into being
through our consciousness through the
agency of our consciousness certainly we
can never know what reality
we're separate from our consciousness is
well i
i don't think we would ever sacrifice if
we didn't believe that reality was
opaque to our beliefs because we we
we sacrifice because we believe in the
possibility of a better future being
brought into
reality by our actions and it
actually seems to work i mean it's quite
remarkable we can imagine something
we can strategize toward it and it
generally me
it manifests itself well enough so that
we don't stop
doing that and it is quite
it's quite remarkable that that's the
case
on that note i hate to break this up
because
we're getting going i know that we have
a heart out
so russell brand thank you so much for
talking to us
oh my god are we done already i know it
was fast
but uh that was fun thank you very much
um where
where can people watching find you
um i have a podcast called under the
skin which is on luminary
i have a book coming out on audible
which i'd love to talk to you about
you know further about the finding the
sacred
in the everyday rather rather grand
title revelation you'll be pleased to
hear
um like uh like where i'm just talking
about that i personally can't
live without sacredness present in my
ordinary life and how i find it
in a post-secular world but when you
were just talking just then sorry to
interrupt my own hard out
but i was like thinking that perhaps
much of the dissatisfaction
polemicism and fragmentation that we're
currently experiencing
is a result of people not feeling that
agency not
feeling like this this the ability that
you say to manifest your reality through
the practice of certain principles
it feels like that we're having a sort
of an externally imposed nihilism that
you can't influence reality but you
can't impact reality
these swathes of disillusioned
disenfranchised dismissed people
it just occurred to me when you were
talking just then i think you can
influence reality that's what i've
decided
it's too weird other doesn't make any
sense otherwise it's the simplest
explanation
when is your when is that book coming
out russell
i think it's in march which might be so
far into the future
as not to exist in the sort of social
space that we're currently occupying
in march how long have you worked on it
i worked in it for a couple of years
sort of like leading up to and
during the pandemic do we still have
march
is march still a thing are there do we
have equinoxes now or equinai
what is reality now
well hopefully we'll return to something
more approximating normal reality when
this pandemic ceases to exist
god willing i'm so um happy
i'm so happy to see you looking so well
and uh to see you both together as a
family as a father
and a daughter and it's very comforting
for me as a father of
two daughters to see you working
together well and to sit and to see so
many of the
principles that you have espoused and
beautifully articulated jordan
manifesting in you michaela
it was a real privilege to meet you both
thank you thank you russell brand
very good to see you again russell i
hope i get to see you i've got your
email i'll be in touch i've got both
your emails
you have a you have a remarkable
capacity to
to dig into things thank you
thank you very much that's a beautiful
compliment from you
yeah well it's quite striking i remember
the last couple of times we spoke i was
struck exactly the same way
is that you have a very fast mind and it
goes very
it goes down a long ways thank you
thank you very much that's a wonderful
compliment
if it were earlier in the day and i'd
made the
giddy life choices to have children in
my 20s i would stay up now
with pornography on another screen and
cocaine on the back of my hand
chatting into the long hours but perhaps
if those were the choices i made
i wouldn't find myself in this esteemed
company
[Laughter]
well have a have a good night yeah have
a good night
good night good night thank you
so we just finished talking to russell
brand yeah
what did you think of that well i told
you i watched rebirth which is his
comedy special from 2018 yesterday
i don't i wanted to ask him but
there wasn't time i wanted to ask him a
couple of questions one of them is
how he's so verbally fluent so i can
just ask you that
like is it he's just really smart or is
it because he's read a lot
and watched a lot or is he just
naturally like that
he's really smart so then the rest of us
that aren't like that or we're just
never gonna be that
he's really smart uh he's also extremely
high in openness that creativity trait
and so people who are high in openness
can see patterns
but a lot of that's that's you're born
with that it can be hurt and ruined
how would that by trauma it's like ptsd
type of
malnourishment oh just brain development
you mean
yeah but a lot of that's that's the way
he is
you know he was born like that i've met
a number of people like that um
camille pellias like that ah she's very
very
sharp and fast ben shapiro although ben
isn't
ben isn't as open as as uh russell yeah
he's crazily open he connects ideas from
all over the place yeah you're pretty
open
and verbally fluent like when i go to
your lectures or when i hear you talk
sometimes you'll go off on a tangent and
i'll be like
he's gone yeah there is no way that
whatever he started
an hour ago has anything to do with what
he's talking about now and then it'll be
like
attach it you'll just attach it at the
end like how do you even remember it's
so funny how do you even remember what
you're talking about it it's like
if you're listening to a great piece of
music like a bach concerto say
um bach will go off on a tangent
and then he'll return to a theme and
it's so satisfying you yeah
yeah yeah and it just flattens you
and it is that it's that ability to make
things come together
it's so exciting to be able to do that
and that's one of the reasons i love
lecturing is that i can
go out on a tangent way out and explore
and then
think okay that comes right back here
and
if i'm in good shape i can do that
continually in lecture
right because i can remember that thread
and i can go back but if i'm not in good
shape when my health starts to go i
can't
keep or remember you can't remember it i
thought
even when we were talking to russell
there were times i thought
i'd listen to his question long
questioning hard
and oh yeah yeah most people
like i said when i when i went like this
i was like that i i don't know what
i was i was there and then he said
something i
didn't know where he was going with that
and then i lost it did you lose it or
were you afraid and let yourself lose it
i don't know what the difference
would be well between those
i i thought i thought that you didn't
give yourself enough credit
and that it was maybe your fear of not
being able to
understand that made you say that
i mean did you feel that there were
parts of the conversation that you
didn't understand
all things considered or were you
speaking specifically about the question
that he asked
that was the question about about the
transformation of the idea of god
it's kind of a highly technical question
i don't think that there are i don't
think there were parts i didn't
understand
um there are references he made that i
didn't pick up yeah
fair enough so that made the questions
more complicated mm-hmm
one i mean luckily i know a little bit
like when he's talking about job and
the reference is there he said one thing
he said um
oh god i can't remember exactly what it
was but it was something about
job's false um
false he said something that just
wow something like he was faking
something towards god
did you pick up on that or no i can't
remember that part specifically
i can't remember it exactly i just
remembered i was like that was weird i
was going gonna comment on it but now i
can't remember
um no i actually do think i have trouble
i think
because of how ill i was and how many
medications i was on
like i've done for whatever it's worth
i've done iq tests
over time and i know it can change when
you're younger and when you're older but
they kind of
this measure that's very stable okay
it's stable well in that case
when i was on medication when i was
trying to get better when i was
22 and so i was taking you know adderall
and i was on
ciprolex and immune suppressants and
tylenol three and antibiotics
and gravel and trying to like stay awake
prop myself awake and things
i hit 122 on a uh
on an iq test and i was like yeah okay
that's pretty good
um i hit 132 after i went off of all my
medication
right and my memory just my memory has
improved
so dramatically like i couldn't remember
phone numbers i couldn't remember seven
digit numbers
so i i honestly believe like when i took
oxycontin for a while it was about two
years after that where my memory just
when i was in class and i put up my hand
i'd be that student they'd call on
and i'd go i don't remember what i was
gonna say and it's not because i wasn't
paying attention i honestly couldn't
remember what i was going to say so i
was writing everything down so i could
remember it
so i i do think you know well part of my
developmental years have
being sick too not not just the
medications but also being sick
has dampened down my ability to remember
even even like questions like russell
was posing yep like it's hard to
remember all the ideas that are in there
yeah well i was having i wasn't sure but
to be fair that was a very he asked some
very complex questions
as well yeah and i think he went easy on
us to tell you the truth
i've heard i've heard him talk sometimes
and
i think he's tired he's good his kids
are dampening there's health
the health is really relevant because i
also find
like identifying patterns like that and
going way out on a tangent coming back
and holding all those things
simultaneously
takes a tremendous amount of energy you
know i found the conversation with
russell took a tremendous amount of
energy and
it isn't obvious to me that i have the
stamina for it like i pay for it
it also makes me wonder how much i paid
for
doing all the lectures that i did in in
in that short period of time from 2017
when i did the biblical lectures through
i get i get people like
i don't know i don't know my in
i've seen you lecture at university and
things and you were on fire when you
were lecturing to the public
like in 2018 particularly and that must
have taken a
massive amount of energy because it was
really long lecture like it wasn't in
how long were you lecturing for
90 minutes yeah so 90 minute lectures
then a q a
meeting people you were eating like four
times a day and then you'd fly to the
next city
right and you did how many cities did
you do 130 to 150
i thought it was 180. no it's not that
many well
it was whatever 130 to 150 okay that's
enough
right yeah in about 200 days yeah so a
lot of people message
yeah well i did the biblical lecture
series in 2017
in the fall and then went to europe for
the book
launch and then i went on the tour yeah
and even the biblical series here
was intense very so i don't know i get
people
i wish so much that i could do another
one on uh on uh
see i can't even remember the book now
the moses the moses
books um exodus because i have all that
material in my head
you're gonna get you know like part of
part of the problem
okay everybody has this if they ever get
sick and i've been sick
so much that i know this to my core
but when you're still sick there isn't
really anything you can do about it
except wait to get better
and then as soon as you're better you
don't even remember the period of time
that you were sick
yeah i don't you're like you're like
that that was
nobody knows how to wait okay when i was
healing my ankle
i repeatedly injured it because i was
like i'm feeling a little better
i'll just and it wasn't my fault really
i was like i'll just wear a pair of
shoes that are a little bit closer to
flat
just a little bit closer to flat and i'd
go a little bit closer to flat and then
i wouldn't be able to walk for three
weeks
and i'd be like that's not fair that's
not because i wasn't paying attention
okay it's just because my body is slow
and when i like i said when i got off of
boxy cotton
it was two and a half years and there
was absolutely nothing i could do about
it
and when i got off of ssris it was the
same thing there was nothing i could do
about it
and then when it's gone
you gotta wait for the time when it's
gone yeah
i don't i don't waiting is horrible how
to live like that because
throughout my whole life i've juggled as
many things as i could possibly put up
in the air
all the time and that was exciting and
fun um
but i watched yeah there is
i don't know how not to do that
i've only been experiencing that
juggling a whole bunch of things now
i didn't experience that earlier and i'm
not very old right i'm 29
i'm almost 30. but i'm only experiencing
the juggling
act now because i was too sick before
it's so fun to see how many things you
can do you know when the forces you get
efficient too in such an interesting way
is
you know you think well you shouldn't
take on more and you think well no
that's not necessarily true because as
you take on more
you get better at delegating and you get
more efficient and so then you can do
more
yeah and it's hard to know when when you
can't do more
well i kind of learned when i was
writing
you know when i was writing maps of
meaning i spent
90 minutes to three hours a day on that
for about 15 years
and at the same time i was raising a
family and
you know although obviously your mom
took primary responsibility for
the continual child care i was around a
lot
and i had my job as a professor in my
clinical practice and all of that
but you can tell if you're doing too
much if you can't sustain it across
days so i would find some days i could
write for five hours but then what would
happen is the next day i could
i was impaired in my writing or two days
later so you have to push yourself to
see
what you can iterate across days and i
found that
i should never write for more than three
hours i wore i wore
myself out so that i was stealing energy
from the next few days
it produced less productivity rather
than more when i worked with
counseling i counseled uh lawyers mostly
who were they were high-end lawyers
working in in very prestigious law firms
and
the deal that my the company i was
working with made with
their firms was that we would work with
them as individuals
but i remember that produce a
productivity gain that would pay for the
treatment
treatment so to speak um and often
lawyers you can measure lawyer
productivity by billable hours
and so the law firms want to push the
billable hours up above 2000 if they can
that's a lot right because there's only
365 days in a year
so that's six hours a day across
weekends and everything
are of solid work yes a billable work
right that's efficient work that's not
administrative work and that sort of
thing
but often what would happen as a
consequence of the conversations i had
with
these people is that we would plan for
them to take time
off it had to be planned several weeks
or months in the future and that
actually made them more productive
i've heard that i've also heard that if
you allow
particularly productive people to work
from home
that they're more productive i was i
often worked from home
yeah and um although there were
conditions for that i
it i had to be a junkyard dog this is a
good piece of advice for any of you
out there who want to write or to pursue
anything that's your own interest is
you have to cordon off a space and a
time for that
and then you have to guard that i always
thought the metaphor that struck me was
junkyard dog like i was a junkyard dog
when i was guiding my time
guarding my time to write and when your
mom would come in i'd snap
at her or you kids it was like don't
bother me
i'm writing and the reason for that was
you know i might have had 30 ideas in my
head
that i was trying to uh that lord i've
got okay
and then if someone came in and
interrupted me
oh that would fall and it'd be like an
hour of thinking and i had all these
plates up in the air and then they would
all fall but
so yes you can work effectively at home
but it's
difficult to cordon off your time partly
because
if you're writing particularly you're
doing something that might
not work like it might not bring any
money you might not be able to sell
it um it's a long-term game
and there are short-term emergencies
that
are always calling out for your
attention yeah that appear
to be more important than whatever
you're doing because whatever you're
doing isn't showing any benefit yet
yeah well that's right it's just a time
suck that has a
question mark for the payoff right
exactly exactly
and so so well you can increase the
chance of the payoff
if you're actually disciplined and
productive so i mean i
i train myself to sit down and write
every day and i wrote
even when i didn't have anything to say
you know it would take me 20 minutes
all the little devils in my head would
be telling me that i couldn't
i wouldn't be able to think of anything
today that there were other things i
should have been doing that this whole
thing was a waste of time and
i'd have to quell all those that's fine
and then then i could write as i wrote
more and more
the amount of time it took to quell
those decreased
and then if i was tired it would
increase again but i found and this is
this might be useful for people too
you can force yourself to sit and stare
at the damn blank
page if you do that every day you'll
write something you'll write a paragraph
you'll write two paragraphs you'll write
three paragraphs
you write a single sentence if you do
that for a couple of years you have a
book
and hemingway wrote something that was
really useful to me too he said uh he
said write every day and
and make that a habit but he also said
stop when you still have something to
say and just make a few notes about
what you have to say because then the
next day you can pick up where you left
off and that was also very useful
that is useful i'm trying to be smart so
i've been i've been writing this
memoir so i think i've had i haven't
really had times when i don't know what
to say
because i'm not at least at the moment
i'm not connecting
grand ideas about the universe i'm
recollecting what happened to me
so i'm not making anything up
not that you're making things up but
it's literally events that happened in
my life so i i don't usually i don't
think i've ever had
writer's block i certainly have the
problem where
i have a whole bunch of other things
especially because i'm juggling
a whole bunch of different parts of
whatever it is i do
uh i have a whole bunch of things that
i'm not doing all the time
there's this huge list of things i
haven't had time to do
and it's always there that's you're so
lucky to have that
i had that for so many years and i don't
have it at all now and it's
killing me the lack of that i just can't
stand not having that
you're going to get it and it was like
that from it's a real pr but it's good
to know that that's a privilege
yeah your life is full when you have too
much to do
and then but then you have to learn how
to manage having too much to do and the
first thing you have to realize is that
it's always going to be like that
as long as you're fortunate and
opportunities keep coming
so then what do you do about that and
the first answer is well you don't wear
yourself out
yeah so that okay so that's something we
could talk about a little bit and
i am i'm completely aware of how
fortunate i am because
i was so sick that i couldn't do
anything like i waited for the periods
that i was really sick especially
especially when i started the diet went
off with ssris and was like
having those kind of severe neurological
problems
i spent weeks being like i just have to
stay alive and i'll just watch tv
and i hate watching tv like i really
don't like watching tv it's a complete
waste of time
um not if you're watching the simpsons i
don't even
i don't even like watching the simpsons
anymore like i don't like watching tv
unless i'm sick and so there were weeks
where i was like i'm
this is what i'm doing and i'm just and
i had like i had this idea i was like i
know i'm going to get better
one day i'm going to get better i don't
know when that is but one day i'm going
to get better
and so i'm going to wait how do you
think you were able to maintain
see i i was angry okay like i had a
couple of good days
where i didn't have any arthritis my
skin was healed and i was happy
and i was clear and my memory was good
and i had a couple of those days and i
was off on my medications and i was like
this exists and i'm not making it up
this reality exists
and so when it went away i thought
somewhere
something i'm doing is wrong perhaps but
that reality exists
and like [ __ ] you world but i'm getting
back
to that yeah and you're not taking that
away and i was like
and i was why do you think you had angry
i'm asking partly okay so i lost it i
know well i don't
you know i had a vision of you once i
remember this
that you emerged i was i was
experiencing some pain
because i'd become more aware of in how
much pain you were in
and i had this image of you coming out
of the darkness
it's kind of hackneyed when you describe
it
but you were on the back of a dragon and
it was the dragon in the chaos and you
were coming out of that
on the dragon right now bursting out of
it that was right before
so that vision was right before i
moved out and it maybe half a year
before i started getting healthy
it was right before if you remember
maybe six months before i started
getting healthy
healthier um so the first time i
experienced that was when i needed my
ankle replaced after i had my hip
replaced
and i was so i had my hip replaced
people watching would know i had my hip
replaced when i was 17 and i was it was
i was in so much pain i couldn't sleep i
couldn't put my hip in a comfortable
position
like usually if you have kind of like a
broken bone it's just
except it was way worse i've broken my
arm and needing a hip replacement was
way worse
i had my hip replacement it was
absolutely brutal i
healed i was healing from my hip
replacement i'd kind of come to terms
with the fact that i was a 17 year old
with a hip replacement and then my ankle
stopped working
and i and i just like it's like it makes
me upset
now to think about it it still hurts
so that's that's trauma like i've seen
that my clinical practice is that people
get traumatized when something bad
happens to them
and then just as they're recovering
they get laid low again boy that takes
the yeah that's just
because you're like i just i just made
it and you're just like climbing up
yeah bringing your head above water and
then you get pushed and you used a lot
of
energy to do that like all your energy
and i was i was on a whole bunch of
medication i was barely holding it
together and i was like oh i finally
threw it and then my and they're like oh
you need an ankle replacement it's going
to be three and a half years of waiting
and i was like i can't wait that long
i'm gonna die
like i'm gonna do myself in i can't not
sleep for that long
and i had like i was in bed you were
there
and i was just like having a panic
attack i had like
i don't know hours i don't know how long
last lasted
hours of pure terror
um because i thought i was gonna kill
myself
um and then i have i don't know how to
explain it but something
snapped and i
and that fear got when what i what i
actually did was i thought
okay how long can i keep this up for
realistically without a plan and i
thought
oh it was i think it was june because i
had my hip done in may i think it was
june or july and i thought i can last
until
nov um october i can last until october
and then i'll start to make a plan right
i'll just
i'll just last until october and then
i'll make a plan so i put that off into
the future
into a bearable moment and then in i
believe it was august we found out that
i could have my ankle replaced because
you did a bunch of
organizing to get it replaced faster and
we found out i could have it replaced in
november
and by that time i had a potential end
date but something happened
that day and i can i remember it kind of
visually that i put walls
sky high like all all the way up that i
could see
between me and
the pain i was experiencing and
like and i turned it into anger and i
can remember the walls going up and i've
had a really hard time bringing them
down and andre's helped me since i got
healthy because
i'd put the walls up between me and
everything that could hurt me
um i don't know if any of this is
helpful but i
all the i can't make contact with that
anger like i've been able to use anger
my whole life you know
it's one of the one of the sources of
energy that i've drawn on even in my
lectures
aggression that energy
put in a in positive direction but when
you're diagnosed
when you're depressed enough like when i
so when when i started the diet and when
i got off of ssris and i started having
those
like hallucinating reactions and i was
really depressed
i didn't have that anger when i was
really depressed
i only got that anger when it when it
came yeah when the depression came up a
little bit there's
no pot like anger's part of emotion yeah
and there was nothing there so
but i i know i knew i had experienced it
so a lot i a couple of things i i got
good at being sick one is i knew that
everything i was thinking was possibly a
lie
because um i was extremely depressed i
was having these hypomanic
periods and i knew how volatile i was
around
other people so so i kind of thought
okay
everything i'm thinking might be a lie
so i have to think about this logically
and kind of
unattach myself um so when i was having
these
reactions and severely depressed and i
didn't have that anger i
just kept repeating you know there was
that one time that i felt good
and i do believe that the body has a
capacity to heal
and so i should be able to heal and get
that again and then i just waited
um and then when i got a thanks
but i made it through man so it wasn't
fun
it was horrible but then also
experiencing that has allowed me
to help a lot of people like i i get a
lot of people who
their their friends and family don't
understand because if you have never
experienced severe illness you can't
understand it even when you
see it and sometimes that means that
when you see it it makes you angry
so a lot of these poor suffering people
who are chronically ill
who are going i'm hurt i'm hurt i'm hurt
look how hurt i am
people are just like stop stop it stop
it stop it right i don't want to be
around that
and it's probably some sort of
evolutionary response to avoid
to avoid the infection i don't know what
it is but sick people
get a lot of hate for being sick well
it's frustration too on the part of the
people
yeah and sadness right and it's a lot
easier to be angry at somebody than
than sad at them well and to understand
what they're going through you have to
allow yourself to feel that
and sometimes if you can't help it's
easier being mad at them than being like
wow life is so unfair right
um so i get a lot of people reaching out
saying
well you know it is that also brings up
the issue
you know i don't know what to think of
this but
sometimes some of that cruelty so to
speak is pushing it's like get the hell
up get
i know it's sometimes people need that
although
you know i'm less certain of that than i
used to be um
well do you think you're do you think
that
what do you think of the way that we
treated you when you were a kid and you
were sick do you have any
residual
um i'm let me let me
answer that carefully for the most part
i think that my illness was so
complicated that
i don't harbor any resentment about it
um
i'm probably still
a little bit
maybe resentful is the right term
unfortunately
about some aspects like when i was a
teenager i drank
and i didn't it's not like especially
after i had my hip and ankle replacement
because i hadn't gone out for
a number of years and i just wanted some
fun right after being like suicidal for
a year
and so i i drank and before that i
started drinking when i was
like fairly young kind of once a week
and i was probably drinking more than i
should have but
i was absolutely miserably depressed i
was
i had this idiopathic hypersomnia and i
couldn't stay awake and drinking made me
feel good
like it didn't just make me feel normal
i had energy um
and i think there was some
blaming the drinking for my sleeping and
my health
and i don't think that had anything to
do with that i think i was using alcohol
as a
you know treatment um
i don't like i don't know i'm not
see your mom asked me the other day if i
felt guilty about the way we treated you
when you were a kid
and well i don't well i mean i can
remember one time when i put you up
against the wall
in the bathroom when you were mouthing
off to your mom
and you were being very disrespectful to
her and i think both your mom and julian
who were also there thought i went too
far
at that point and i think probably i did
i was doing it to some degree
calculated like i wanted i well you were
probably trying to break through the
haze i was in but like good work
was trying also to ensure that you
didn't act in a way that would alienate
you from your mother
yeah i'm i think like but we you know we
we
i think it was extremely complicated and
you talked about how
sometimes negative i guess
pushes can push people out like there's
some people
there's the fact part of the problem i
have with the fat acceptance movement
there's a whole bunch of problems
but one of them is there are people who
are
okay it's complicated i've heard from
people who were
pressured to get thin who got thin and
healthier
i've heard from people who were
pressured to get thin and they ate more
right so it depends on the person but
you always know well the same with
disciplining children is the
disciplinary strategy has to match the
child
well and the parent for that matter
there's no one-size-fits-all
you know you were much easier to
discipline especially when you were a
little kid than your brother was
it was easier to stop you when you were
misbehaving
i've noticed that scarlett doesn't
respond to
um negative feedback
really julian was like she doesn't
really care she's just like
yeah who are you yeah i'll just go do
what i want
and i'm like what i don't really can you
talk about
the offers that you've got recently yeah
that'd be fun i've been i've been
thinking of um doing i used to do
you put up some q and a's on youtube
and do kind of more personal stuff
um and i haven't mostly because
we've been dealing with health things i
think that's actually the main reason
but also because i was like
well people probably want to hear the
interviews more but
now that i've become more sure of myself
i think i might start the q and a's up
i don't think necessarily that people
would want to hear the interviews more
i mean when i did q and a's they were
they were extremely popular
now i like more popular than the
interviews yeah that's interesting
so yeah i think i'd like to do them
again but we should start doing them up
again
like when you were thinking about it
what you have to like you're going to be
limping along for a while
because you can't go through some health
catastrophe
and then pop back up and it's really
annoying
especially if you're a hyper productive
person and i've talked to a lot of
people who have sick kids
and they they go oh i'm so like i'm
feeling so
horrible for this sick child like
everything is unfair
and what i've told them is one
i think that they can get better right
if you look
everywhere for answers but two it's not
as hard
in my experience it wasn't as hard being
a sick kid as it was being an adult that
was sick
because if you're healthy and then you
get sick you have a comparison
like when i when i grew up and was
limping around all i did was adjust my
movements so it didn't hurt as much
i didn't think damn it used to be better
when i could run
right so it's gonna be harder and then
when i got healthy
right and then like went off of all my
medication and got
sick kind of again in a different way i
was just like you're kidding me or when
i got pregnant my arthritis came back
i was just like that's what made me
angry i guess
because i was like how is this happening
again um there's gotta be a way out
but it's harder psychologically as an
adult
for sure but you you're gonna have to
limp along and do
like do podcasts and do q and a's and
that's
way more work than most people are doing
but you're not holding yourself to a
most person standard so that doesn't
matter
if it's more than most people are doing
people work
media wise yeah that's what i meant
i mean it's not 14 hours it's not 14
hours waiting tables
right yeah which is work yeah
for sure okay yes we're clarifying that
i'm not
i'm not ditching on waiters i was a
waitress my feet hurt
right i didn't really enjoy it right i
didn't enjoy it at all
um but i just i mean
produce and then wait and one day you're
gonna snap out of it
and then you're gonna be on top of the
world
and i will be here to tell you that
repeatedly throughout this period of
time
but uh opportunities that i've had um
well some summit called the canadian
wealth summit this is
so random um i said in
well i've said i i say yes to everything
right for now
although i say no to some things now
which is nice
like oh i'm at the level where i can say
no to a few things that's kind of cool
um but the canadian wealth summit
reached out and asked me to do some of
their
like are you saying are you choosing
between things
i'm choosing between things i'm choosing
between things that's not the same right
knows when you could do it and you say
no choosing between things is when you
don't have enough time to do all of it
yes that's true i'm not just arbitrarily
saying no i'm judging opportunity and
saying no to the ones that
don't make sense right clarifying that
so that everybody listens yeah oh this
is that
thanks good to have you here yeah um
but i have an opportunity to
to interview edward snowden
and a bunch of other like potentially
very interesting people
and so like one of the things i've been
trying to do with my
brand or whatever it is is i kind of
started in the food
health kind of sphere i was doing
conferences at paleo fx and
ketocon and low-carb stuff um and that
was because
that's because of how shocked i was that
food mattered i was like oh my god
everyone look i'm
cured how long did your mom tell you
that
yeah but she didn't say only eat beef
okay
like she said it's food somewhere
but if she didn't say it was all foods
who was gonna tell me that